but I I think trans women still have
like more strength than women like
but even saying that like that
they say that's suspicious to me
I didn't want to come off as someone as
a man accusing women of not being
feminist yeah that's exactly exactly
what you did that's exactly what you did
and because you got a pink uh Pig
whatever and Luke kind of sus because of
that people let that [__] slide gay
dudes and trans women they could come
into women's spaces and talk crazy to
women that's just a fact walking away
from this I really want to educate
myself more on transgender women
I'm a feminist I am a feminist I'm a
feminist I'm a feminist I'm a feminist
I'm a feminist
[Music]
all righty how do we feel about women
having rights yes how do we feel about
women's rights yay no guys I want to be
taken seriously yes equal pay guys let's
learn negotiate again all right really
cool thing awesome the more the merrier
what would you say is the most feminist
thing about you yourself I believe women
should be paid the same across the board
not just white women but women of color
you can be a person of color and not
believe that women should have the same
rights as I as a black person so that's
why I'm a feminist hey we got some
intersection now let's see in the
building what kind of feminist this kind
of that
the best kind because they consider all
of the layers of Oppression yeah okay so
first you got the top one that's where
the cream filling is right that's where
you just have all of that whipped cream
all the all the little sprinkles on top
that's where the white women live yeah
and then you have the layer below this
is where a lot of the minorities live at
that's where they got the meat of the
cake the good stuff the ones who are
really fighting oppression and suffer
tremendously and then you have the base
of the cake the part that no one really
wants to enjoy we put disabled people
there because you know
yeah and with that that's how layers of
Oppression work every layer on top of
the other just deepens the burdens on
the other but an intersectional feminist
will start at the bottom eat the
disabled people and then eat the black
people and then get to the white people
at the end that's how it works back to
this video feminism is about women being
equal period yeah yeah for me it's just
like uplifting women's voices for
women's rights I think like a good thing
for us to start like how do you guys
Define feminism it's like an advocacy
for equity in the institutions like I I
looked over and I saw like not to hate
anyone that wears running shoes but like
I saw the running shoes and I just
assumed anti-feminists like right
Wingers dress more for Comfort than
style so it's just a stereotype that I
was playing on my eye immediately went
to Emma I was like that very much could
be a conservative woman in this group
just based on her outfit it was a great
outfit she looked great it's funny how
the people that don't want to be
discriminated against discriminate like
that just the outfit that's not very
feminist of just the outfit but if you
choose certain types of clothing you're
going to deem not a feminist because in
now you gotta be dressed like a Butch
Queen cause
that's so fast because then if you wear
the little skirt you're using that and
the male gaze and you want that
attention on you that's not very uh you
know I think it's incredibly
anti-feminist to Typecast a woman
because she dresses in an attractive
manner or you know shows yourself
absolutely that's literally what a lot
of workplaces do to women who dress
attractive absolutely and it's funny to
see uh supposedly Penman is do the exact
same listen listen feminism about
freedom of choice but why are you
choosing to be attractive you [__] it
up now you're supposed to be ugly that's
what feminine is supposed to be I guess
my view on feminism is that it goes
beyond women as well like we include
trans people in there and like by
uplifting women and trans people you
then see a better society and
environment for like men and like other
people you said something about agreeing
with women no matter what they do like I
fully disagree I feel like feminism you
have to hold women accountable like
there are women like JK Rowling who
likes leaving and spearheading and
transphobia movement in the UK and you
can't like hide behind feminism when you
were literally hurting women oh totally
I I feel like that was just like a broad
statement when you say supporting this
is what happened when you start
including trans women and all this stuff
that's what happens right lgbtq done
[__] up putting the T in there because
now they got too many issues they got to
deal with they have nothing to do with
the LGB and now these trans people will
just be like yo listen feminists that's
how we do the [__] job and women are
like all right I guess there's I guess
they're driving the bus now
there's This Woman's there like I want
to support women trans women say excuse
me [__]
they're some of these women that you're
not supposed to support with your sexy
ass
which I think makes you a conservative
it's crazy not limited this trans woman
come in and basically tell people how to
feel should I try a woman
I don't think she's a trans woman I
think she's a queen either between I
think she's a butts Queen
when you're dressed like a weed head
skater is that still Butch yeah it's not
just Dutch no it's not a term that I've
apprecially I've heard Dutch queen no
butt screen
I was in a workplace run by men I feel
like I couldn't stand up to like the
plate and step up and really like talk
about how I'm feeling because I would
just get shut down so I think like in
those situations I mean like if there's
like no one that can like support
someone that you should support them and
educate them in a way what do you
usually do in instances where you're
like shut down by a man in power you
could say well nowadays it's different
okay if I was saying a few years ago I
would just kind of like well then just
go about and do what they want me to do
but now I have a voice and I will kind
of there's not like something equal I
will just point out the fact that hey
that's not fair like it's just a thing
of being strong and powerful I think
yeah a loud platform for women to speak
let their voices be heard because that's
the most effective way to dismantle
ignorance his speech seemed very
practiced or thought out it didn't seem
natural I think also just putting women
in leadership at my work all of
leadership is all women yeah and I feel
the safest there I will say that
traditionally I have had issues with
women being my boss but
I was here
[Music]
foreign
she's a little too comfortable and
uncomfortable at the same time if that
makes any sense yeah I think a lot of
women who are feminists feel soon
it's like they might not feel what like
trans women belong in women's sports but
doesn't mean they're comfortable saying
it out loud for fear like repercussions
for a lot of women actually most of
their existence is having a difficulty
of expressing themselves in public or in
places and taking up space so for you to
see that kind of behavior be like I
don't think she's a feminist it's
because your idea of a feminist is
always someone loud proud with blue hair
you know like my girl Destiny or
something and that's not the case for a
lot of these women
you foul for that [__] I'm just saying I
just I thought the girl I thought the
bush Queen was was Named Destiny was
like I don't think her name is blue Air
Disney
I'll say this I think people's
perception of a feminist is always the
loud person like at marches and rally
but a lot of women who identify
feminists don't feel comfortable even
talking in public spaces you know so
it's just interesting that their
perception is always based off the
social activist and not actually most of
the people who take up the movement I
think most feminists are not feminists
oh okay that came out of that field but
go ahead
most feminists are not feminists at the
beginning of the thing feminism was
supposed to be about equality now it's
not so much about that and the ones that
think like yeah it is still about an
inequality they they don't understand
that it's not anymore it's not about
equality it's not about that they're not
fighting about everybody to be equal
they're fighting about women to have
more push wherever it is supposed to be
so it's not the people that are the
people that are
not feminist and don't consider
themselves feminists but really believe
in equality are more feminist than a lot
of feminists that claim they are
when I speak to feminists sometimes they
come out and they they really don't see
how the inequality that man can face
towards women they they they put that
aside
but they just prep up women on every
side so it creates a place of not
equality but handicap so women have an
they want women to have a handicap over
men on some things and then when other
things are not assessed they don't talk
about it
so it's not about wanting to have women
being equal everywhere it's wanting to
have women equal in certain things over
man
and man can't really say [__] about that
or uh contest or have a word or have a
discussion if I can't have a discussion
or talk to you about it
we're not equal if I'm not able to be to
to be like you know what you were wrong
on that point I think we should discuss
that no you're being a bigot right away
that's not equality you want handicap
you want to be able to always talk and
me to shut the [__] up and not say
anything and that's and in some spaces I
feel like that's how they feel they make
you feel when you have them there they
want you to shut up they don't want you
to say a thing or yeah I think you're
wrong on there no you just don't think
I'm already I'm putting the case of a
bigot every time I speak up and most
people that really are just for equality
and fairness are not feminists they just
want everybody to be equal in the best
way possible and those feminists well
they don't want that they want handicap
understand what I'm saying
good luck everybody thanks man all right
black guy and the girl in the pink are
going next let's wrap this up I want to
expand on what you said
I'm wondering how you guys feel about
trans women in women's sports I'm down
for it I'm a trans person myself
foreign
woman how they whatever the [__]
pronouns are the entitlements
to the feminist movement the way this
person talking about a trans issue she
too comfortable and the way she thought
about women's faces she's too
comfortable so she gotta be both and I
think the root of that problem tends to
stem like with like we're protecting
children but you can't say you're
protecting children if you're kicking
out trans children it is like a
non-starter and it distracts from I
think more imperative issues with like
the Banning of gender affirming care and
like housing and I want you to peep this
we're talking about feminist issues and
somehow the trans women issues have
already taken up 25 to 30 percent of
this conversation just say it's just
interesting how that happened right even
though they account for listening like
one percent even less than that of the
population somehow they just they find a
way to take up a lot of airspace that's
one of my biggest problems with like
modern day feminism is that it tends to
Center Rich CIS hit white women and I'm
like that's weird how do you feel well
yeah I just want to see because I was
wondering I don't know how the casting
rice I don't know if there's any turfs
or swerfs in the group because I don't
determine that to be feminism because
like for me trans women are women's
yeah yeah killing me so the the game the
gay dude and the trans women are out
here oh hell no yes sir you know what it
is this is maybe just the way I think I
don't care what nobody says I feel like
you know the whole trans women or women
but at the end of the day when it comes
to the women's movement trans women
should be considered guests at best
okay that's how I feel I feel like
you're a guest you ain't live the female
experience your whole life okay you jump
into it later on and then all of a
sudden you want to act like you own the
[__] and you gotta direct the whole
thing that's the part that's weird to me
I think it's fine if you want to lump it
in together and fight for both at the
same time as you see like you a little
too comfortable telling women how they
should feel I didn't even think this was
possible but they really got me on the
[__] video thinking like yo my
feminist Queens why y'all letting them
roll over you like this this [__] both
of them just got together and form the
Superman Megatron and and one of the few
actually like born females is feeling
quiet look at her body language
you ready for this she talked earlier
about how when she's in work places she
felt like she couldn't talk around men
and she would just get bullied now she
either supposed in his face she's being
marginalized and she's being told she
made me to shut up and being told her
experience and all this other stuff is
actually perfect
McCain cake perfect Emma what what do
you think you haven't said anything um
I'm kind of like I'm I'm not against it
I'm not like so much
I feel like I don't have a clear answer
because in like with like kids
like when you talk about kids doing it I
don't think the children I think
everyone should like everyone's the same
they have the same strengths and
everything like that but I think in like
professional sporting situations I and I
might need to educate myself more on
this so this might be like what I need
to come out of today and do
this is it you know what it is like I
don't feel like I don't really have an
idea on it it's just that I don't feel
like I'm really comfortable in that
dress because like sometimes I I'm not
sure maybe maybe I don't know maybe
um wow maybe I'm not educated uh I don't
know I've Got a Woman
um well
make it
can I wear something more comfortable
she's not comfortable in that dress
y'all forget the dress she's not
comfortable strike two hold up hold up
she's a feminist
not comfortable talking in a feminist
space but I know this to be true because
if you guys knew the amount of feminist
who hit me up in the privately like yeah
we appreciate what you said about this
issue when it comes to like it's just
fascinating this is like it's so perfect
that the movie was created with certain
groups and like those same groups are
now feeling like disrespected by it
we're going on tour we come into cities
near you we want to see you
[__] face to face where you at
we gonna be doing shows all summer well
this summer we're doing three shows
we're doing Detroit Pittsburgh and
Washington DC but afterwards we were
going to England we're going to be going
all across America Asia so if you want
to get tickets make sure you guys go to
the website all right put your name so
we can email you as soon as those
tickets come out for your area we won't
bombard you with nothing else okay I
promise yeah
um we want to see you guys at the shows
we meet us we have meet and greets we're
gonna have a lot of fun we're gonna be
laughing so it's gonna be a good time uh
but we want to see you guys but I I
think trans women still have like more
strength than women like
but even saying that like that
they say did you people say my God she's
not even lying say Emma you did nothing
wrong you did nothing wrong and I
support you keep going women but I feel
like it's not even exactly she compared
trans women to women uh referring to CIS
women as the women and like kind of then
referring to trans women as not women I
was like oh that might it might be her
um like they have an advantage you would
say yeah like a slight Advantage so you
might be against it maybe I mean see I
don't want to say that though because
then I'm not really supporting all women
yeah you know she's come down to the
moral dilemma she knows what the right
answer she's not comfortable doing it
because of fear of ostracization
I understand it as I understand it and
once you get over the
much like Moses set my people free okay
you know what you need to say you know
how you actually feel about it you just
don't want to be canceled socially for
it it's okay you don't want to be a mean
person but you know the truth is
actually the uh said let my people go
same thing
Let My People Go it actually happened
like seven thousand years ago nobody
knows what he actually said true they
just remixed that [__] you know what the
thing is yeah that was certainly not
English
most of the one who parted the Red Sea
get carry on okay okay but um so if it's
professional let's be honest if you're
good you're good I think if a
transgender woman went up to play tennis
against Serena Williams and it's a
transgender woman she's probably more
than likely lose yeah
did Serena Williams just lose against
like the 200th ranked man no she said
she would
she knows she know no no no no no no no
no she said it happened no you're right
you're right she didn't say nothing it
happened yeah it was documented so when
we talk about strength and stuff
sometimes it's just skill yeah so I
think special like there's some that
like the absolutely even but I think in
very limited areas of sport than like
there might be a slight Advantage but
things here like tennis and soccer like
those type of things are all skill no
they're not no they're not stop oh my
god listen I know you don't want to get
canceled my girl but no even tennis even
it's not all skill oh my okay this
[__] brain rot Hey listen a lot of
people get mad at trans women in sports
when in reality majority of trans women
that compete in sports currently aren't
doing that well it's not like there's
like a crazy big Advantage
um a lot of them are on hormones for
like a long time like it's even gotten
to the point where we're trying to make
a CIS women who have high testosterone
way lower so it's a regulated thing so I
wouldn't worry too much about it yeah
because you don't do it you know those
like some of the most unathletic people
are all here just sitting here having a
conversation it's just crazy to me that
they're this confident and they're this
wrong and all of the a lot of the
government bodies have already been
Banning trans women from participating
in international events and they're
doing it based on scientific studies so
let's keep watching well I'm a lot of
times let's just be what we call it what
it is it's just it's about people's
religion it's about your ideology your
religion yeah yeah and which again you
know you know has no place and they're
shielding their hate yeah because Jesus
said so
when the question of sports came up Emma
immediately kind of withdrew and also
like as a trans person I'm just
immediately like that's suspicious to me
perfect we got rid of the transphobe
let's carry on with this real discussion
goodbye
I'm pretty sure there's like one third
of all feminists probably say trans
woman should not be in women's sports so
this idea that it's outlandish for her
to say that she's got to be conservative
is just funny to me but I would actually
think that it's actually more than that
probably it's just that they shut the
[__] up with that [__]
good luck thank you
Delight turns green that means you have
voted out the mole and you all win the
lights turn red that means the mole is
still in the box and you lose
[Music]
I knew it
[Applause]
May the mole step forward
yeah
there is no mole
yeah my bad I'm so sorry
they just
yeah put all right hey Jubilee
that's it good job casting yo
yeah see we're not haters yes you're not
haters yeah we all do well I like that
you do well I like that you got you all
be [__] you got came out cause even even
if in the beginning it was like
they got yeah even in the beginning it
was like yo Step Up step up they're
looking at who no it's all you it's all
you and the things that you oh you did
good you did good the mole actually
never showed up but we still wanted you
all to play the game
I was shocked I was for a certain week
we kicked out the mall
we were done case closed and I feel like
I was probably too quick to judge I
think it's an interesting social
experiment to see infighting even Within
These groups getting a bunch of
feminists in the room and seeing who
points to another one and say I don't
think you're a feminist extremely
interesting to me and also extremely
interesting that I was the first one out
not really not really but I felt some
hesitation about coming on the show just
because I didn't want to come off as
someone as a man accusing women of not
being feminist yeah that's exactly
exactly what you did that's exactly what
you did and because you got a pink uh
Pink whatever and looked kind of sus
because of that people let that [__]
slide that's what it is listen gay dudes
and trans women they could come into
women's spaces and talk crazy to women
that's just a fact that's just a fact
that's crazy that's a fact that's a fact
that's right that's a you can't even say
nothing to me because if I would have
came in with half that energy they'd be
like oh [__] the entitlement ooh this
that that which is okay I don't even
want to be in them spaces I ain't even
tripping yeah because it's a really
weird position to be in I'm like is it
corny to go on a show and be like a male
feminist but like no it shouldn't be I
think walking away from this I really
want to educate myself more of a
transgender women
you did nothing wrong
like I just said you did nothing wrong
you felt really uncomfortable because
they was ganging up on you that was Stu
two and a half Against One
two other dudes were shutting up but it
was two and a half against one that's
what happened all right well that was it
for today's video I actually like this
one I think it was very telling they did
good
um in the same way that some people deny
folks are Blackness you see that
[Music]
and I just think it's crazy that this
group that the maid the group The the
people that the group was made to serve
are now being ostracized in their own
spaces for not catering to other groups
yeah not catering to the gay dudes and
what they want to say politically and
not catering to the trans women it's
just fascinating how that happened
um but that is I digress what do you
think
I don't know to me it's like it's like
having a group on like who's black and
having white people show up and start
telling me what it is or what it is it's
like what and that person is like I
lived in the Bronx I'm gonna tell you
how you were stupid that's wild but
anyways what do you guys think we want
to hear directly from you fast
that's good